yes with John crumb Miller of chess
collectors international welcome to the
show John we had a great exhibition
yesterday with all those beautiful sets
I know you're not playing any kind of
chess on those sets I doubt those those
folks who collect and all you had a
bunch of your colleagues here as well
tell us about the show sure and there
there are two main kinds of sets the
ornamental sets and those you would
never play with those are very
ornamental intricate or shaped like
elephants and different pieces we see
some pieces here being shown some lovely
pieces and though that's an ornamental
set certainly the playing sets though
you actually that's the reason I started
collecting was as a player there's
certainly not not anywhere near your
your level but to be able to find
antique sets that one could play with
and be able to play games with them
granted blitz is not super easy with
those but but it's certainly certainly
possible you don't have your kids
playing with these sets to you know they
my kids fortunately of well they're
older and so they they don't get near
them they don't break them but they
think they like them to a certain extent
but so sir okay do folks have a
personality around collecting like some
people like to collect from collect from
certain errors or from certain regions
of the world what's your philosophy
around collecting my collection is
antique and that's kind of a theme of it
I was really drawn to the history aspect
of it so I collect sets from the 19th
century 18th century and earlier and I
have gaming pieces that go back to 3000
BC in his Valley gaming pieces pieces
from Mesopotamia from 2000 pc so the
gaming aspect of it through senate for
instance which is an egyptian game and
in the Egyptian pyramids are those types
of things marching up through the middle
ages and that's when chess course really
comes with the forefront so you're
saying game piece is not chest because
chest we don't have any proof of chess
going back that far um the current
thinking is the chess started at 500 ish
ad it wasn't earlier as far as we can
tell but there were eight by eight
checkered boards illustrated in the pier
heads which isn't yes but my collection
I have the gaming pieces but the vast
majority and really my interest is as a
chess player is is the chess aspect of
it so in 19th century 18th century and
some earlier like 17th century but but
to your point other collectors collect
from mod like modern sets you know
Simpsons and characters and those types
of things or from some collectors
specialized one collector specializes in
african sets and that is his absolute
love another collector specializes in
early American sets most of which are
bakelite which is a type of plastic and
you know that type of thing so yes
collectors have specialties and areas
that they they focus heavily on what do
chess sets have to tell us about history
and culture around the world they have
quite a lot to tell us about history and
culture because the cult the chess sets
were were developed within a certain
culture so the the Indian sets which
that for export were from the India from
from in the Indian population under the
kind of under the auspices of the John
company now I'm thinking 18th century
19th century for British export and so
they they made made those sets china
similar to today you know China
manufactures and manufactured so much in
terms of chess sets for export to the
British market and for other markets for
instance one of the sets that we just
looked at was a king george set it's the
its european vs asian and the kitten the
White King and Queen are king george the
third and queen charlotte for the
british market but for the french market
it's Napoleon and Josephine course so
yeah it's all it's all the cultural
aspect of it is really embedded and
embodied by the the pieces tell us more
about it to your talk I know you gave a
talk this morning to the to the
collectors what did you talk about
actually it was around the call it was
called cultural threads and it went
through the at cultural aspects of chess
sets around
the globe and through space and time so
we looked at the interesting and unique
aspects of chess sets from different
places at different times like let's
take French Dieppe sets of the
eighteenth and nineteenth century the
bishops were all contorted like gesture
type things called foo or full and so
that was specific to that time in place
it was actually a little bit of a
chiding of the church to have to have
that in there because the bishops are
traditionally you know bishops of the of
the the church background so that was
part of the aspect of that fascinating
tidbits in each in each era absolutely
well it's a great exhibition we would
recommend everyone go see it it's here
at the Hall of Fame just for a few
months and thank you so much John crow
Miller chess collectors international
great stuff to talk about Thanks so
that's one more question to John
actually I know that there's been recent
legislation that's changed the trade of
ivory and some of the restrictions on
that and that that's a theme that
actually comes up in your show how that
that debate and how it plays out so you
could speak to that sure well and it's a
really important and relevant issue the
overriding issue and there's no question
about this is that poaching of elephants
must stop and must be stopped most
forcibly be stopped through it can't
just be regulations it has to be through
money invested at the point of poaching
to prevent it that simply must happen as
a corollary many people are interested
in banning all trade of ivory which
certainly makes sense to a certain point
the point where it starts to perhaps not
be as congruent is for the very antique
ivory and the reason is that there are
many families with family heirlooms
musical instruments antique firearms
many of which have embedded ivory and if
those then become outlawed which they're
on the brink of being
outlawed in effect then those families
are making a sacrifice and yet not a
single elephant is saved by those
actions and so the actions that have to
occur are the ones that will save the
elephants that's what we need to pursue
so I understand the mindset behind it
but there is somewhat of a disjoint
between what's going to be effective in
saving the elephant population and and
what's actually a symbolic gesture that
doesn't help very much but it does hurt
people who own that you know those
family heirlooms you're talking about
history and culture affecting chess and
vice versa thank you so much for joining
us thank you and one thing is the chest
fair that I'm supposed to mention which
is at the hall of fame tomorrow 11 22
with many interesting chess sets for
sale that people want to stop in and and
see those that's a very interesting in
their own right side definitely come out
to that enjoy the weekend here going to
the chest collectors international show
seeing all these beautiful chess sets
and of course enjoying the action by the
finest players in the world